-We are coming to you live
every night this week.
A very special thank you
to everyone in the audienc
for being here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Usually when you're out
in new York city past midnight
on a Monday, you've made
some pretty bad decisions.
But you guys are here
on a good night.
Gwen Stefani is here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love Gwen Stefani!
Not only is she a music icon
she's the only reason I know
how to spell the word "bananas."
Well, today was
the first day of fall.
Did you know that? Yep.
This morning, I put on
my favorite flannel shirt
and scarf,
made some hot chocolate,
stepped outside,
and realized it was 90 degrees
Saw it was 90 degrees
in New York today.
It was so hot, Trump asked
the president of Ukraine
for some inside dirt on the sun.
[ Laughter ]
You guys hear about this?
There's a giant new scanda
involving the President.
Trump asked officials in Ukraine
to investigate
Joe Biden's family.
Yeah, Trump asked Ukraine
for election help,
or, as he put it, "I was jus
trying to make Putin jealous."
Apparently, Trump asked
the president of Ukraine
to investigate Joe Biden's son
Right now Eric and Don Jr.
are thinking,
Damn. He even pays more
attention to Biden's kids.
"Papa?"
[ Laughter ]
-"Papa!"
-Today reporters asked Trump
if he did anything wrong.
He was like, "Yeah,
I probably should have asked
for dirt on Elizabeth Warren."
[ Laughter ]
Trump's call with Ukraine
could really --
Take your time.
-Yeah.
-Take your time. That's right.
We're in this together.
[ Laughs ]
Trump's call with Ukraine
could really put
his presidency in danger.
Today Nancy Pelosi said anothe
500 or 600 major violations,
and we might think
about impeachment.
Actually, Nancy Pelosi tol
the White House to hand over
the secret whistleblower
complaint by Thursday
or face the consequences.
In response, Trump signed an
order that eliminates Thursday
"It now goes Tuesday,
Wednesday, Friday, Nancy.
There is no Thursday."
The whole thing
is pretty shocking.
We spent years
talking about Russia.
It might be Ukraine
that takes down Trump.
Who saw that coming?
That's like looking both way
before you cross the stree
then getting hit by a drone,
you know?
Now Trump's lawyer,
Rudy Giuliani, has been
all over TV defending him,
which brings us to another
installment of
"Rudy Giuliani isn't helping."
♪♪♪♪
-Did you ask the Ukraine
to investigate Joe Biden?
-No, actually I did --
-So you did ask Ukraine
to look into Joe Biden?
-Of course I did!
-You just said you didn't!
♪♪♪♪
-Not helping. Not helping.
-Wow.
-But Trump is in New York City
to give a speech tomorrow
at the U.N. General Assembly
He's speaking
to a roomful of leaders
with different cultural
backgrounds and ethnicities.
It's basically Trump's version
of walking into a haunted house.
He's like, "Aah!"
[ Grunting ]
[ Laughter ]
But Trump's speech
will be a little different
First, he'll make
some opening remarks.
Then he'll go around one by on
asking world leaders
for dirt on Joe Biden.
Just like that.
Over the weekend, several
2020 candidates were in Iowa
and Joe Biden set up a ten
with a bouncy castle,
a fire truck,
and an ice-cream truck.
It's all part of his plan
to win that coveted
3-to-8-year-old demographic.
Meanwhile, Elizabeth Warre
has been surging in the polls,
and she now leads Joe Bide
and Bernie Sanders in Iowa
She's pretty confident.
I mean, here's Warren arriving
in Iowa over the weekend.
-[ Crowd chanting ]
Warren! Warren!
-Yeah.
But here's how she felt.
-[ Crowd chanting ]
Warren! Warren!
-Oh, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
But it's not all good news
for the candidates.
New York City mayor
Bill de Blasio
announced that he is
dropping out of the race
and he'll eventually support
another Democrat.
When they heard that, all
the other Democrats were like,
"Please not me. Please not me.
Don't look at me."
Oh, and this is
very Interesting.
I heard Nestlé is gonna star
selling luxury handmade Kit Kats
for $17.
They came up with the idea
after asking,
"What does nobody on Earth
want or need?"
And, finally, over the weekend
an American Airlines fligh
had to make
an unscheduled landing
after a passenger
started smoking a joint.
At first, all the other
passengers were furious,
and then not so much.